hola santiago pues aquí todavía se puede
oler y sentir el humo en el ambiente
aunque el incendio ya ha sido controlado
son en total 350 los pacientes que han
sido evacuados a otros 4 hospitales de
los alrededores se han trasladado a los
pacientes más complejos a los que
estaban entubados entre ellos pacientes
cobit que requerían por ejemplo de
cuatro o cinco asistentes cada uno entre
ellos dos funcionarios de salud
especializados en temas de alta
complejidad y ahora en este momento se
reubica en aquellos pacientes más leves
aquellos que no tienen tanta gravedad la
situación se encuentra controlada pero
se vivieron momentos muy tensos esta
mañana en santiago en las inmediaciones
de este hospital en que la humanidad
llegaba a verse desde varios puntos de
la capital parte de tranquilidad hasta
el momento entonces patricia es
prematuro pero ya las autoridades se
están contemplando algún tipo de
hipótesis que me imagino que habrá ya en
marcha también una investigación
pertinente para esclarecer qué fue lo
que sucedió
así es la fiscalía norte se atrasa hasta
la zona ya se ha abierto la
investigación y las hipótesis
preliminares puesto que los funcionarios
todavía no han podido acceder al área
del hospital donde se produjeron los
hechos puesto que existe el riesgo de
que éste se desplome apuntan a un
cortocircuito que se originó en la zona
de calderas y que se extendió
rápidamente al resto de el hospital y al
resto de esa área del hospital
tenemos que tener en cuenta que las
últimas horas santiago dividió un
sistema frontal y aunque ahora tenemos
un sol y un día despejado en la última
noche llovió mucho se especula que
alguna filtración de agua habría
producido este cortocircuito patricia de
qué tipo de hospital estamos hablando
qué tipo de centro médico es y sobre
todo tengamos en cuenta que estamos en
emergencia por el joven 19 y cómo
impacta esto a los santiaguinos
así que se trata de un hospital popular
en un barrio humilde es un hospital de
la red pública donde existen muchos
inmigrantes y familiares de inmigrantes
ingresados por eso se habilitará un
colegio cercano para que los familiares
de los pacientes que han sido evacuados
puedan permanecer aquí existe mucha
preocupación entre los familiares que se
enteraron muchos de ellos por las
noticias puesto que la prioridad estuvo
en el traslado urgente de los pacientes
y no en la comunicación con los
familiares y se vivieron momentos muy
tensos en la red de santiago está
funcionando en este momento como una red
integrada por eso se ha trasladado a los
pacientes de este hospital tanto a
hospitales públicos como privados y se
ha realizado un traslado bastante
coordinado y efectivo teniendo en cuenta
la situación de saturación que viven los
hospitales de chile como del resto del
mundo ante la situación del tobillo
mundial
patricia muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad de santiago en chile el
incendio entonces en este hospital de la
red pública ya ha sido controlado